so this is the sony ericsson w89 TI it's
Sony's latest Walkman phone and you know
I have to say Danny for the company that
invented the Walkman I think this is
still kind of like Sonny's still kind of
clueless about how to make a music phone
really yeah I think so yeah you like a
little bit the thing it gets right the
most is this well with the phone go oh
nice
it's pocket-sized and actually it is
totally it's nice and thin and when you
put it in a pocket Josh it's you know
forgets there you know versus like a big
clunky iPhone which is kind of like
omnipresent it's true this is feels like
it's about half the size of an iPhone
but how my guys about have to wait about
half the screen real estate to that is
yeah we're getting to one of the
downsides there yes
I have to I have to say though that as a
media player the controls just don't
feel that intuitive to me I mean I feel
like okay I know there are these
controls here but they sort of do dual
purpose as media and phone controls but
they're I don't know the buttons still
feel a little tiny to me it's too easy
to press other stuff they are trying to
do there are a little tiny but what Sony
Ericsson does is they kind of cheat a
little bit when they bring up the media
player great interface yeah so you can
see yeah - my point exactly like a
little cheat sheet right there for what
buttons correspond to what media
controls that's a problem right there
because if you have to show a little
picture of the controls here to explain
what those controls are for that's a
sign of an interface failure in my book
oh yeah
pause rock superstar Beck it has a
pretty good speaker I'll give it that it
sounds I'm in you know typical small
phone speaker it sounds really trevally
and tinny but you can definitely tell
what the music is you can hear the
sounds well enough to hear the words
there's no base to speak up but that's
fine if you just want to play a little
it's not friends yeah let's talk about
another thing which is this little port
here
that's a headphone port that is not a
standard headphone jack no that's some
crazy Sony Ericsson proprietary thing
and I am NOT a fan of that I'm not a fan
of that either that was very annoying
because you know I have like some pretty
good headphones and you have to get a
special headphone adapter to plug it
into this phone uh in other aspects the
phone you know as a web browser I don't
think it's that great the browser is a
typical clunky small phone browser it's
almost like an afterthought it's really
hard to use too and I think it's not a
fully standard web browser either
because there are some dropdowns on the
wired web site that didn't pop up I'm
not sure exactly what the problem is but
the phone is not an ideal web browser
does have 3G though so once you can get
to a site polys gotta pull up pretty
fast what's the bottom line
Danny how does this score as a wire calm
review well surprisingly enough is it
scores a seven out of ten second out of
town
I've been talking about all the ways in
which this phone sucks right now you're
telling me that this is a recommended
product I do recommend it and there's a
reason why I do recommend it because
it's a good phone a phone as a
communication device is used to make
phone calls you can talk verbally with
one another voice and this one is
actually a mobile you can take it
anywhere you want it actually works very
very well calling people out the voice
quality was was crystal-clear a lot
there than many other phones we've
tested out and then the fact that it's
so small and so easy to port around
makes it you know were an ideal ideal
companion
you